u.s travel experts say the industry has
suffered more than
500 billion dollars in pandemic related
losses just since march
unemployment in the travel business
soared to 51 percent last spring
that's more than double the national
rate at the height of the great
depression
sir richard branson is the founder of
the virgin group which consists of
dozens of companies including airlines
hotels
a cruise line and the hyperloop which
will be able to go three times faster
than a high-speed train so richard
branson joins us now
i want to talk about the hyperloop in a
second because it looks so exciting sir
richard good morning
but first i want to talk about the
travel industry
we've got a we've got a new more
contagious uh strain of the virus out
there which has led to
tougher travel restrictions what do you
see this doing
to the travel business in the near term
well look it's been very very tough um
you know being in things like airline
businesses or cruise businesses
um and our wonderful teams have just had
to be very inventive
so uh first of all they've turned
most of the planes into freight
freighters
um moving uh doubly doubling the amount
of freight that they normally
travel um uh you know things like you
know vaccinations and
and and other other goods that are
urgently needed to
get from country to country um i think
that what the travel industry is waiting
for
and and delighted to see you know like
britain and america moving really fast
now on
vaccinations uh is the population to get
vaccinated
in britain in about three months time
the vast majority of people will be
vaccinated
um and you know once the whole
population is vaccinated
everything can get back to normal
america which is our principal
customer as far as virgin atlanta is
concerned um
again hopefully 150 million uh people
will be vaccinated over the next
uh three or four months so i you know
we're hopeful
that um we'll come out of this sir
richard you're friends with
with with president biden have you been
able to talk to him at all about what
could be done here
um i haven't spoken to him since he's
been elected um but he's got a
good team of people um and i'm sure that
they'll
you know really are one one message to
him is you know
roll out the vaccine as quickly as
possible 24 hours a day
um you know just make sure that
everybody is persuaded to take it
and so that you know little businesses
um well everybody then
can get back to their their normal
day-to-day life yeah sir one
yeah oh sorry sorry to interrupt there
uh sir roger tony decouple here uh
once upon a time we met in paris i was
one of an array of journalists who
interviewed you
uh ahead of the paris accords back in
2016
the biden administration has announced
that america will re-enter those accords
to combat climate change and reduce
greenhouse gases
your industry travel is the single
greatest emitter of greenhouse gases
some people are ashamed to fly because
they think it's such a problem
you make money that way so what do you
want the bite administration to do
to address the problem what are you
willing to do to address the problem
well um the paris talks was a great
breakthrough
and every country in the world signed up
to it and
uh only we never ever expected america
to
to walk away from it and i think that
all of us um need to play our part
um and you know i mean virgin set up
organizations like the carbon wall room
that's now merged into the rocky
mountain institute
to help companies all over the world to
um to take as much carbon out of their
business
businesses as possible um and you know
there's a list of other things whether
it's the bt
or the elders that we've set up to try
to try to address
uh help address the problem um i think
that with this administration
you know they they've set goals of um
get getting to
carbon neutral uh by you know um well
about by 2050 and and and i think
with business leaders and government
working together we can get there
um airlines you know they're becoming
more and more fuel efficient
means that virgin atlantica boredom much
much more fuel efficient and much less
carbon emitting
um and and that that you know that that
needs to continue
step by step sir sir richard michelle
miller here
uh once by the time we met in jeddah
saudi arabia on a sustainable conference
tour that's amazing
anthony have you ever met i wish
i wanted you that necker island i want
to talk about
this hyperloop it's you you turned out a
a con concept video i've got to know how
close
are we seeing this happen
well um we've had a very exciting year
in technology generally at virgin
whether it's virgin galactic
taking people to space virgin orbit
putting satellites into space
uh now virgin hyperloop having had its
first you know people on virgin
hyperloop
um but these things do take time i mean
you know by
um you know over the next six or seven
years i would hope
that what our first hyper fully fledged
hyperloop system
uh will be up and running uh quite
likely in
what you mentioned uh you mentioned
middle east that's quite likely
um india is is very likely um obviously
we'd love we'd love to see one of the
first
um in america as well where hyperloop is
you know version hyperloop has been
developed
um virgin hyperloop is ridiculously
exciting i mean
it it will take people as you your
program already said three times the
speed of the highest the fastest train
in the world
um which means that if you you know on a
sort of four-hour
uh car journey you'll be able to get it
you know get get there
in half an hour um and you know it's
going to make amazing
enormous difference if you you know at
one airport you we can connect
another airport and effectively make the
two airports into one airport
and and go straight to the gate and
unload people
you know at their gates they can just
get on the plane and and
fly internationally so richard you
yourself went on a test ride a couple of
months ago what was it like
um i didn't i would love to have done um
but um josh geigel and a lovely
wonderful lady called sarah
josh you know was the person who really
conceived the idea of
a virgin hyperloop and built it from
scratch they they took the first seats
and and they loved it and um obviously i
wanted to jump on
jump on the next text flight um but you
know hopefully i'll be able to go on the
next one
all right so richard branson we thank
you we should also say before he goes
uh mr branson sir richard 10 out of 10
on room raider that is a gorgeous
we've seen a lot of zoom interviews yeah
this is absolutely the best yes
it's a welcome reprieve from us here in
winter in new york yep
they um it's one of the advantages of
getting older you're able to have that
sort of privilege
yes very nice so richard branson thank
you so much for being with us this
morning we really appreciate it